[Musik]
aufgewühltes land die proteste in
washington sind die bisher größten seite
im tod des afro amerikaners george floyd
autoritäre alleinherrscher in belarus
formiert sich protest gegen langzeit
präsident lukaschenko notlösung
finalturnier die basketball bundesliga
sucht unter zehn teams den deutschen
meister
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen bei den nachrichten an diesem
sonntag mit von der partie ist norbert
lehmann für den sport ein schöngrün
antwort von mir und wir schauen zu
beginn noch mal auf die demonstrationen
die der gewaltsame tod des schwarzen
george floyd ausgelöst hat so
hunderttausenden gingen die menschen
gestern weltweit auf die straße doch in
den zorn über die ungleichheit in
amerika und anderswo mischt sich mehr
und mehr die hoffnung auf veränderung
zentrum des protests ist die hauptstadt
washington das weiße haus abgeriegelt
und verbarrikadiert davor versammelten
sich zehntausende um gegen rassismus
polizeigewalt und auch gegen die politik
von präsident trump zu protestieren
friedlich aber entschlossen aus den usa
elmar theveßen
sie feiern das leben denn die
demonstrationen im ganzen land sind wie
hier in philadelphia keine trauermärsche
sondern signal des zusammenhalts der
bevölkerung gegen rassismus und polizei
über durch washington strömen rund
100000 menschen friedlich und
entschlossen etwas zu verändern in
amerika diese menge hier sieht aus wie
amerika schwarz-weiß asiatisch latino es
ist den menschen wirklich wichtig manche
behandeln schwarze menschen nicht wie
sie sollten
die nationalgarde mittendrin der
präsident hat nun per tweet angekündigt
sie abzuziehen alles sei ja unter
perfekter kontrolle und viel weniger
demonstranten als erwartet dabei tragen
doch immer mehr ihr anliegen an das
weiße haus heran sie bekommen auch
unterstützung von angesehenen
persönlichkeiten
wir müssen der verfassung folgen der
präsident hat sich von ihr entfernt
das ist gefährlich für unsere demokratie
und unser land und diese massive protest
bewegung die größte in meiner lebenszeit
zeigt dass das land sich das nicht mehr
gefallen lässt stehen sie schlange um
george freut die letzte ehre zu erweisen
am kommenden dienstag ist die beerdigung
in houston auseinandersetzungen zwischen
demonstranten und der polizei gab es an
diesem wochenende auch wie hier in
seattle
aber sie blieben die ausnahme auch heute
wollen die demonstranten friedlich ihren
präsidenten klar machen dass er den
zusammenhalt des landes gefährdet auch
in deutschland sind am wochenende
zehntausende gegen rassismus und
diskriminierung auf die straße gegangen
zu einer kundgebung in münchen waren 200
menschen angemeldet es kamen aber mehr
als 100 mal so viele
friedlich verlief auch eine
demonstration am berliner alexanderplatz
dort und in hamburg löste die polizei
die demos wegen überfüllung auf danach
gab es einzelne auseinandersetzungen
rund 100 menschen wurden festgenommen
gesundheitsminister sparen äußert sich
besorgt über dichte menschenmengen
während der korona zeit der kampf gegen
rassismus brauche unser engagement aber
auch bei wichtigen anliegen gelte
abstand halten maske tragen aufeinander
achtgeben und pandemien besser bekämpfen
zu können fordert sparen eine so
wörtlich europäische gesundheits nato
europa müsse sich im fall einer
gesundheitskrise gegenseitig
unterstützen und schnell handlungsfähig
sein und wir schauen auf die aktuellen
krone zahlen in deutschland bleiben die
neuinfektionen auf niedrigem niveau sind
aber leicht gestiegen
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 320 menschen neu
angesteckt mit einer rückflug garantie
will die lufthansa ihren passagieren die
sorge vor reisen in der korona zeit
nehmen
wer zurück will den bringen wir zurück
sagt konzernchef spur touristen
beispielsweise die am zielort wegen
erhöhter temperatur nicht einreisen
dürften oder weil etwa im gastland des
virus ausgebrochen sei der flugverkehr
ist seit monaten eingebrochen ein
milliardenschweres hilfspaket des
staates soll der lufthansa nun helfen
china meldet seit wochen kaum neue
corona fälle doch die wirtschaft des
landes steckt noch mitten in der krise
das zeigen die zahlen für mai der
außenhandel brach um 9,3 prozent ein
das liegt vor allem an den importen sie
sagten massiv ab die exporte fielen
dagegen nicht so stark wie erwartet
am ersten juli übernimmt deutschland die
ratspräsidentschaft der eu innenminister
seehofer will sich dann stark machen für
eine reform des asylrechts
nach seinen vorstellungen soll bereits
an den eu-außengrenzen geprüft werden ob
ein migrant asylberechtigt ist wenn
nicht müsse er zurück geführt werden
kritik kommt von pro asyl mit seehofers
konzept würde der rechtsstaat an der
eu-grenze ausgehebelt und jetzt einblick
in den osten sie wird wenig
schmeichelhaft als die letzte diktatur
europas bezeichnet die regierung in
weißrussland oder belarus wie es jetzt
offiziell heißt seit 1994 kurz nach dem
zerfall der sowjetunion ist dort
alexander lukaschenko an der macht und
nachgiebig und uneinsichtig corona ist
für ihn tabu
als einziger staatschef feierte er mit
einer riesigen militärparade 75 jahre
sieg über hitler deutschland
im august steht seine wiederwahl an doch
plötzlich regt sich widerstand wie für
begann berichtet mit der pantoffel gegen
die kakerlake mit freien fairen wahlen
gegen den autokraten alexander
lukaschenko
das wünschen sich tausende die heute den
kandidaten der opposition ihre
unterstützung zu sichern
wir hoffen dass wir etwas verändern
können denn wir sehen wie sehr sich
unser volk danach sehnt wie bereit es
für eine ehrliche abstimmung ist er will
im august präsident werden valerie zepp
carlo
die botschaft des ehemaligen diplomaten
und geschäftsmannes belarus muss
modernisiert werden und zwar rund um
alles na ja nicht alles aber die
industrie die landwirtschaft das
gesundheitswesen die bildung und die
staatliche verwaltung müssen wir
reformieren
denn lukas schenkel wirkt alarmiert
letzte woche tauscht er plötzlich die
regierung aus der neue ministerpräsident
kommt aus dem rüstungssektor in einem
treffen mit seinem geheimdienstchef war
und lukas schenkel dass es in belarus
keinen mai dann keine revolution in der
ukraine geben werde
auch ohne uniform sind sie gut zu
erkennen
polizisten und geheimdienstler seien
heute verstärkt unterwegs heißt es aus
minsk auch die zahl der verhaftungen
scheint zuzunehmen
das ist unterdrücken sie kommen in zivil
es ist so dreist und zynisch die leute
einfach so von der straße weg
mitzunehmen jeden tag passiert dass ich
bin es leid in so einem land zu leben in
belarus braucht es mut die staatsgewalt
so deutlich zu kritisieren
und dennoch wollen viele nicht länger
schweigen und 19 sport und zu norbert
uns zur fußball-bundesliga der frauen
genau da hatte ja gestern serien meister
wolfsburg durch den sieg gegen frankfurt
vorgelegt und die tabellenführung
ausgebaut aber verfolger bayern münchen
der legte heute nach durch ein
souveränes 5 zu 1 gegen turbine potsdam
bayern coach jens scheuer zeigt flagge
gegen rassismus seine spielerinnen
drehen in potsdam mächtig auf linda
dallmann mit der führung nach 17 minuten
sehenswert der zweite münchner treffer
die serbin jovan damjanovic längst ins
rechte obere eck turbine potsdam völlig
überfordert linda dallmann erhöht noch
vor der pause mit zwei weiteren toren
auf vier zu null
immerhin gelingt den gastgeberinnen in
der zweiten hälfte der ehrentreffer wie
aus dem nichts mehr götz 64 minute ein
sehenswerter volleyschuss in der
schlussphase trifft mandy islacker auf
der gegenseite zum 5 2 1 bayern münchen
bleibt auf kurs champions league turbine
potsdam muss die nächste heim pleite
verdauen
und in der fußball bundesliga der männer
wird die luft für den tabellen
vorletzten werder bremen immer dünner
nach der 0 1-heimniederlage gegen
wolfsburg im zweiten sonntagsspiel
trennten sich union berlin und schalke
eins zu eins zum finalturnier der
basketball-bundesliga da hat der gäste
an titelverteidiger münchen gegen ulm
gepatzt bayern konkurrent alba berlin
dagegen gewannen heute gegen frankfurt
alba berlin wird seiner favoritenrolle
gerecht aber es ist ein hartes stück
arbeit gegen außenseiter frankfurt die
hessen in blau sind zunächst das bessere
team führen zeitweise mit zehn punkten
differenz erst im vierten viertel können
sich die hauptstädter entscheidend
absetzen
dank seiner distanzschützen gewinnt alba
berlin mit 81 zu 72 und startet
erfolgreich in das drei wochen dauernde
finalturnier in münchen
berlins aufbauspieler peyton sie war mit
16 punkten erfolgreichster werfer dieser
partie insgesamt 36 spiele werden in den
kommenden drei wochen in münchen
absolviert bis der deutsche meister dann
feststeht
ich glaube was von mir danken alt und
schon sind wir bei den wetteraussichten
im nordwesten und im süden schauer
mancher orts gewitter sonst wechselnd
bewölkt und weitgehend trocken
richtwerte 14 bis 22 grad
und so ähnlich bleibt es auch in den
nächsten tagen so viel von uns an diesem
sonntag schön dass sie dabei waren